what is popping my whole homies it is me
Mt and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show yo how is it already the finale of
Rick and Morty season 7 y'all time sure
does fly when life keeps exposing you to
Horrors Beyond human comprehension H but
that's 2023 for you but anyways thanks
for coming on down to this breakdown of
this super deep and dark finale y'all
there is a whole lot to talk about here
so let's just jump into this thing but
before we do give this video a like
because it really helps Paul and I with
making more content for you guys because
the algorithm lets us lingam Mo when you
hit that fingo you know what I'm saying
but anyways the episode starts with
Richard and Mortimer walking through a
haunted house of actual Horrors that
would cause my ass to drop a crappy in
my khakis like I can't even do haunted
houses in real life without screaming
like a hyena in labor so the fact that
these two are so unfazed by all of these
actual Abominations surrounded by unborn
fetus eyeball trees is a true Testament
to just how unfeeling towards everything
Rick and Morty have become which very
much serves as an an extension of this
season's trend of showing us just how
much Rick's chaotic influence on Morty's
life has severely warped Morty's mind
like how Morty told Rick that his school
felt like they had to phone Homeland
Security after doing a psych evil on
Morty in episode 99's Mort Ragnar and
when we got to see the origins of an
apathetic evil Morty in episode 5's unor
tricken anyways as Rick and Morty began
to walk through the carnival of
nightmares we can see this creepy Yellow
Jack in the Box ride next to what looks
like a clown lady happily hanging over
over a dunk tank full of knives while a
crowd of people including a small alien
child and an interspecies human alien
couple all gather around to watch a
creepy clown lady potentially die but
then again clowns are creepy as so
I totally get it to be honest but
anyways amongst that crowd is of course
everyone's favorite fear hold dealer
played excident by actor extraordinaire
leave shriber and holy does this
man put in quite a performance in this
episode like that monologue between him
and Morty about how all happiness in our
lives will eventually end was a stunner
and a bummer at the same damn time and
it's probably a scene that I'm going to
be thinking about for a long while but
anyways our editor Matt pointed out to
me that this fear hole dealer guy
appears to be modeled after Rod Sterling
from The Twilight Zone which I thought
was a really nice touch but anyways
after this mysterious man promises Rick
and Morty the scare of their lifetimes
they all head to the scariest place of
all time a Denny's late at night
oo and although most Denny's have
disgusting toilet holes on of you know
the Denny's this Denny's is different
because one of their toilet holes is a
hole that manifests your deepest fears
Rick and Morty's parody of the mirror
cave hole from Star Wars episode 8 The
Last Jedi a Star Wars movie that
everyone universally loved and nobody
has ever overreacted to whatsoever in
The Last Jedi on Luke's antisocial
planet of H2 there is a Subterranean
cave that is strong with the dark side
of the force and it's also a cave that
manifests your greatest fear much like
that woodsy cave area on the planet
dagaba that Luke Skywalker Journeys into
when he experienced that vision of
himself as Darth Vader representing his
fear of falling to the dark side in the
Last Jedi the mirror inside of the hole
on H2 shows Ry that her greatest fear
was being alone and that she'll never
find her parents alive as represented by
her being disappointed to find only
herself like I really love how this
episode uses Star Wars as a basis for
the whole story because Star Wars as a
whole has always been a story about hope
versus fear which is why Luke Skywalker
famously tells Ry that confronting fear
is the destiny of a Jedi in Star Wars
the greatest of Jedi are always put on a
path where they are forced to confront
their worst fears and it's only when
they overcome being controlled by those
fears that they truly become a real Jedi
like how Luke rejected the dark side
after he refused to kill his father and
the emperor in fear or how Ahsoka
recently rejected her fear of her former
Master's Dark Side by remembering all
the good things that Anakin taught her
before his own fear of losing Padme led
him astray Morty being forced to
confront his fear of being seen as
replaceable by his grandpa Rick is
significant because that fear is
precisely what sent evil Morty to his
own Dark Side path like evil Morty
snapped after Rick rejected to give a
damn about Morty's concerns about being
treated with respect like Rick straight
up told Morty that he did not care
whether or not he tagged along with him
on his adventures as a sidekick after
Morty complained about being shoved
through yet another alien ass on yet
another quest for yet another score of
cosmic energy Crystal that fear became
real for that version of Morty and so
that Morty responded by letting his fear
turn to hate sending that Morty's ass
tumbling towards the evil Morty dark
side but anyways I also found it
hilarious how the stall with the fear
hole in it also had one of those old TV
VHS carts that teachers used to roll out
into classrooms when they were hung over
and didn't feel like teaching for that
day like trust me nothing compares to
watching Tarzan in a dark classroom in
the '90s with all of your classmates
instead of actually learning like that
ruled man then when Rick and Morty
watched the bathroom fur hole tutorial
the VHS tape transitions to a previously
recorded Mountain Dew commercial
featuring The infamously cruel former
leader of Libya muamar Gaddafi who was
killed in 2011 by his own people however
right before that transition happens you
can see the eyes of the fear hole
salesman turn pitch black which is
definitely on my personal list of top 10
things that I do not want to see while
my hand is on my wiener at the urinal if
I see a man with dark eyes while I'm
trying to make liquid I'm not going to
be able to go then after Morty jumps
into the hole like a lunatic both Morty
and fake Rick their pants from the
experience and head back home to their
family watching the cake or fake show on
interdimensional cable a show parody on
the fake cake internet Trend that we
first Learned was among Rick's favorite
shows back when Morty became Summer's
quad in episode 7 of this season but in
this episode it looks like we have a
literal piece of cake or pie tied up
instead of a human person which is good
it's better than not have humans cut
open for entertainment ideally but that
is of course interrupted by a half bured
and dying younger Rick who tells the
Sanchez family that he managed to save
his version of Diane from Rick Prime's
garage grenade anyways after Rick and
Morty both agree that they're still in
the fear hole Rick immediately accuses
Morty of being afraid of not being
needed by Rick if his wife ever came
back into the picture which of course
ends up being pretty spoton in the end
but then in order to get more data fear
hole Rick decides to get closer with
Diane and take the entire family out for
ice cream while Beth and Diane compare
their notes about Rick they both remark
about how much Rick hates time travel
and how he thinks it's the Long Island
ice tea of Science Fiction which is
something that Rick has brought up
before in the past but after Rick upsets
Diane by telling her that everybody in
this fear hole reality is just like a
non-playable character in a video game
he apologizes to her by sending a robot
with breakfast to her door with that
robot quickly having an existential
crisis and revealing that Rick also put
memories of a human child inside of it
which is super messed up but this isn't
the first time one of Rick's robots has
had an existential crisis like that with
one of the funniest and earliest
examples of that being of course the
robot that freaks out at the realization
that the only reason it was made was to
pass butter around to the Sanchez family
but soon after this we learn that Rick
and Diane met after Rick was
commissioned to build a law enforcement
drone for the federal government in the
past so I think that the implication
here is that Diane herself used to be a
federal agent of some sort then later on
when Rick and Diane go drinking after
alienating Morty at the park we can see
that the alien bar that they go to was
placing bets on who could drink the most
with Rick receiving five votes Diane
three an Alien named slark getting 10
and an Alien named glar getting the most
votes with 15 it was honestly so great
to see Rick and Diane in a loving
relationship after never really seeing
anything about the relationship over
these past seven seasons of Rick and
Morty but it was equally just as sad to
see Rick have to confront his fear of
his happiness with Diane Ending by
choosing to save Morty instead of eating
tacos with Diane in more ways than one
if you know what I
mean I'm an idiot but I found their
conversation on how different the TV
show Lost ended in each of their
universes to be quite hilarious but I'm
getting ahead of myself here when Morty
sees that Rick looks like he's about to
die from the whole feeding on his fear
of Happiness Morty tries to do as many
things as he can in order to induce
fearful scenarios and hopefully break
that simulation with the first thing
that Morty does being marching straight
to his school with a wellth thought out
list of what he loves about Jessica the
most on a piece of notebook paper and
knowing Morty that list probably took
that squeaky voice Child hours to make
but anyways Mor's top four things that
he loves about Jessica are apparently
the smell of her gym shoes the way that
she says succulent that Jessica's name
means foresight in Hebrew and how
Jessica's Perfect Skin makes his weener
hurt which is a little bit too much
honesty but this of course causes
everyone but Jessica to laugh with
Jessica even appearing to look at Morty
with a super concerned look on her face
so either Jessica felt really bad for
Morty in that moment and thought the
gesture was somewhat sweet or more
likely Jessica just had PE later on that
day and didn't know where to hide her
smelly shoes from that yellow shered
freak morer but anyways Morty then Falls
flat on his face in front of his
schoolmates in front of a parody of
7-Eleven before signing up for his
school plays production of the 1997 Play
3 days of rain by Richard Greenberg a
play that Morty performs badly in in in
the nude like the dude's peeee was out
embarrassing couldn't be me but then
Rick of course jumps onto the stage to
save his grandson with a rap battle just
like they did in season 2 episode 5es
get Swifty but after they both jump
through several layers of fears one of
the final layers of fears Morty has to
go through is his fear of becoming just
like his pathetic Papa Jerry which
causes him to live his entire adult life
in this fear hole we even get to see
Morty turn into the 26-year-old version
of Morty that we saw get created in the
rebuild of Morty store at The Citadel in
season 5 episode 10's Rick Mari Jack and
they also found that little uto moving
van that adult Morty rides in to be
stupidly hilarious as well like the UT
toe is literally just a toe as the
mascot saying I toe which are the kinds
of stupid ass jokes and puns that your
boy lives for but after Morty finally
realizes that his true fear is being
seen as insignificant to his grandfather
he finally emerges out of the real hole
with the episode ending with a super
sweet moment of Rick putting his
grandson's photo on the wall of brave
souls who would boldly go into the hole
but after an episode about a dark fear
hole we catch up with a poopy buttthole
in the post-credit scene because since
this is Rick and Morty a season cannot
end without a state of the union with
our favorite top hated man a man whose
life has continued to crumble due to
Rick causing him to lose his job
marriage and family throughout the
series Mr PB uses one of Rick's Portal
guns to knock out a variant of himself
before tossing that variant and his
portal gun inside of the portal to
replace him in that Universe also Mr
Poopy butthole can be happy again which
is very much like Rick did with multiple
versions of his family throughout the
series but what's super crazy about this
ending is of course that final look of
Suspicion and Malice that Mrs poopy
butthole has about her husband and while
it can be assume that she just suspects
that her husband was just replaced by
another copy of her husband I think
another implication could be that the
variant of Mr Poopy butthole that was
native to this universe was someone that
Mrs poopy butthole grew to deeply resent
possibly due to that Mr Poopy butthole
being a more evil version of our Mr
Poopy butthole what am I saying what are
these sentences that I'm saying I don't
know God I'm 31 a potentially darker
version of Mr Poopy butthole that our Mr
Poopy butthole just sent to Rick and
Morty's parmesian universe but that is
all just a theory of course but it would
be so dope to see this as a setup for a
potential evil Mr Poopy butthole in the
future but anyways that is it for this
breakdown of the Season 7 finale of Rick
and Morty thank you guys so much for
watching all these videos y'all you guys
are amazing I really appreciate you guys
taking the time to hang out with me you
can follow Me @ mastertainment on
Twitter or Instagram or YouTube or
wherever I am on the internet including
the Guardians of the pxy podcast that
you can find on YouTube but most
importantly follow heavy spoilers here
on YouTube and make sure to hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss
anything that we upload and again hit
that like button if you like the video
always helps out the channel but yeah
thanks again for watching you guys are
amazing and I will see you guys next
time goodbye